hi everyone my name is Tamara chambers
and I'm Doug and I'm shocked we don't
have a costume for this one there's no
devil horns or anything for what the
hell do you do for this one I did look
for my inchworm beanie baby but ya know
I have no idea we could do something but
it would get flags
[Laughter]
this is Tamra's never seen and today
we're watching the human centipede
yeah um I don't know if excited is the
word it's not I don't even think curious
is the word um but I've made so many
jokes about the movie I figure I should
see it I'm hoping he has a good sense of
humor yeah like that's kind of what I'm
hoping I have no idea I heard everyone
that's seen is like well you get exactly
what it advertises hi so for me cut gore
kind of stuff if it's just for shocks
sake is super just not what I'm into
like some of the saws have a few clever
things but usually it's just kind of
like I just don't want to see someone
ripped apart this if it has a sense of
play you're in luck the knocking ripped
apart they're getting sewn together I've
actually I've seen the third one in this
series the best well good this would be
like the prequel this would be like the
Phantom Menace of human sense oh and
that's what we really want yes Human
Centipede of Phantom Menace so there
that should be on the DVD yes Phantom
Menace of course oh god let's just do it
yeah
towba fest well can't act like we didn't
know we were getting ourselves into
it's a story about people coming closer
together that's a really it's a
character piece yes
how'd Malcolm put it it's like twister
except with a lot more mouths Oh God I
didn't like it it made me mad it was
kinda no it's kind of like what parents
say they're not mad they're disappointed
yeah I can't act like I enjoyed or you
know and into it in the slightest um but
it gave exactly what it promised I don't
know it's one of those things were like
you know somebody's like I'll give you a
dollar you know a way if I can slap you
okay and then you're angry you get
slapped it's like well yeah that's I
mean I watched the movie I knew yeah you
know you know you're getting yourself
into
it just it's very much like those films
you watch out of morbid curiosity very
more like you're not getting anything
out of it except for unease cuz I think
they had a good sense of humor in some
parts I but I wasn't like laughing from
any like humor that was put in the movie
I was laughing for like
uncomfortableness and just like kind of
awkwardness sometimes yeah which I know
that's the idea in a terrible way I get
why movies like this exist you know it's
kind of along the same lines of like
Texas Chainsaw Massacre in some ways but
this is kind of a different kind of
exploitation where it's like let's just
take this totally ridiculous idea and
the kind of the shock value and the kind
of comedy comes from how real they're
treating it at how much they show it
yeah fair enough I don't like it at all
I don't get it during the week that's a
good way to put it like I understand why
it's being made my favorite thing though
is that like in the credits like six
people made this and did everything like
boom mic and ride are the same people
not really I don't think so but it's
like six people's absolute passion
project what but but like one okay it's
either six people's passion project or
it's like one guy who wrote in director
who just must have been the world's
greatest pitchman it was just like look
human
to feed they read the script they're
just like yes I won't put money on this
man I won't put my life savings into
this human centipede I have two sequels
ready man I'm ready to go I mean yeah
you're not wrong what it was and also I
think the guy they got for the science
the doctor I think he was great yeah of
ten I was about to say nobody's a bad
actor in this but that's not really true
the opening especially at first we
really thought we were gonna have fun
because oh this is gonna be like the
room like everyone's just acting you
know not the worst but just bad enough
just bad enough where it's funny
the two women particularly in the
opening where they're in Germany even
though there is nothing to indicate it's
Germany aside from them just saying
they're in German yeah when the
centipede came together when they were
one the acting surprisingly improved it
sounds awful to say on so many levels
but they actually they act very well
with their eyes yeah I have to imagine
as an actor it must be like terrifying
like that's that would get you in like
you they say in acting school you need
like a trigger to get you into the
moment that's a I I think we're just
talking the whole time like just imagine
getting up every morning just like I get
to be the human centipede and just like
you just talk with this actor you're
gonna know very well because your ass is
gonna be under fire or the ass is gonna
be on their mouth and stuff like that I
just imagine like at some point the girl
in the middle they called cut and
they're just sitting there waiting for
the next thing and her just being like
what am i doing let's be fair the acting
in the beginning she did not go she did
a story I think it's fine there's
nothing like surprising cuz you go and
shoot already knowing what's gonna
happen there's no like clever things
outside of it something that it's never
been done before
I don't think making people into
centipedes but it wasn't at all like
the script wasn't exciting to me no I
mean it's again it really gives just
exactly says it's gonna show you what
it's like to really be this you'd be in
this human centipede how do you eat how
do you do that how do you walk out here
all that stuff and that's the idea of
the film and again that's it's so
straight up that's what it is and it's
like okay that's what you gave us but
yeah there were no twists or turns or
anything like that even at the end
sometimes they'll make some really
stupid mistakes like these two cops come
in and they're like well we think
something is up is like well do you have
a search warrant it's like no you you
stay here we're gonna be back in 20
minutes and bring a search warrant and
you're going down it's like what dumbass
cop does that wouldn't you'd either a
keep all of the cops there to make sure
he doesn't leave while you get the
warrant or be you just be like oh he's
got us later and they get the search
warrant to come back cuz of course he's
got playing something stupid things with
like these people trying to escape like
he's swimming at one point and the human
centipede is like I know we'll do we'll
crawl away but he's like in like right
next to ours yeah it's like we got this
the doctor was fun he was legitimately
creepy and uncomfortable it's like the
same time where you're kind of scared of
him you're kind of laughing at him too
what I like and I think that was
intentional particularly the scenes are
he's like you know yeah no come here
dawg come here ha ha ha I'm like this is
somebody's fetish into this yeah like
something is like my dream is finally
coming true watching this thank you
Hollywood here's me
I always think - I've always thought
like what would be the role that I would
say no to and like I don't know that
there is one I feel like I would have
seen it and I've been like I mean I feel
like it'll be big cuz it's so crazy I'll
do it and then like I haven't seen those
people in anything else because
everyone's just seeing a person's ass
next to them instead of a different
person yeah yeah like I can't see you
without you know the person's spinal
cord going through your mouth um it's up
to be two and three they're all just
that weird thing that you watch out of
this
gross fascination and then once you do
you're kind of like I didn't need to do
that
but I felt that I needed to I didn't
need to what's so funny is that I hear
like a lot of people didn't like the
first one for the exact opposite reason
you would think they if they wanted more
of like the surgery and the gore and
stuff like that and that's what the
other two do apparently and to me it
sounds more like if the gore you know
it's over-the-top and that one that like
I would just sort of be used to it in
that phase by we're with this one
because it is just so much of their
acting and their eyes and them moving
how do they move and how that you see
just a little bit of it in the mouth and
stuff like that it's like that's
creepier to me and that's like more
disgusting and disturbing and stuff I
think I definitely agree with that I
think there were definite moments of
unease that was brought by the acting
and they're like little that you did see
and I think it was effective it's just
something that I never needed to see it
surprisingly I could have gone through
life without this idea and still be a
perfectly full human being well thank
you for joining me for my last Tam tober
fest of 2018 it was to go out I thank
you so much for watching I'll see you
guys next week with November hey have
you seen Ken the Hat
[Music]
[Applause]
you